рівно за 2 тисячі гудрич in this дня
підписання мінська 2 деталі проговоришся
макет буде вичерпаний самотньо
руйнуються на думку експерти в Києві та
барменів говорю в цьому моді як пров'язати
і в тіла не покладено мінських на рік до
дату віскозі вибухом росію
ви до неї своєї чисельно забав я за
звук рамою сюди вигляд ви до неї оружня
звели на не за ручних цей вид нову
україну та повного контролю над кордоном
автора також нікому до криво пролітали
приставки до прання не мечами то
президента франції та провали по парі дні
і переговори захисні спокій не
порушення бойовиками рудому пунктуації
вогні
ти близько джанні роботі місії все окей
дафана освоюйте
його ходжес товщу ми далі друкуємо він
з паном Порошенко фон і робити його
найсильніших на махані їх німецькою за
зовнішню політику на полі, а там його треба
сильно не прогресу в комплекті на сході
україни я хто ви вимагати мінську думав про
насті
година для тіла у чоловіків бо мінська
процес може рвати і вічно червоним
побачу маму чуді шанс і чоловікові і весь у
продажів руку ви канат юніцький думова
насті
зуму халупу дві сторони спи проти там
вчилася я вас і шансу в тебе. а смужка
z порізати на кубики порошенко заявляв
ще 2016 стану роком поверни донбасу
петлю розбито всі україни та проведення
місцевих виборів на окупованих
територій за українськими законами
перестану днів і задерикуватих темп зустрічі
merck або порошенко така сама кит мад
централізації в тому три сотні року сила
верховній раді
для вниз і землі до конституції
президент поки не травня